he's Chris Sims who joins us pro
football talk co-host and NFL analyst
now Phillip Fulmer recruited you to
tennis you almost went to Tennessee
right did I'm when I mean I went on TV
and put the hat on and did everything
how many hats did you have in front of
you only one I knew who I was going
there to make that decision so I just
had it off camera and put it on in fact
it wasn't even big enough that should
have been my sign right there wasn't big
enough to fit my big head we had cut a
slit in the back of it to make it work
you still have that Tennessee hunt no I
do not know that was the toughest phone
call I ever had to make in my life maybe
to this day still but being you know
what was I 17 18 years old at the time
and I David Cutcliffe left Tennessee to
go to Ole Miss and he was the one who
recruited me is the one I had the
relationship he's a big reason why I was
going there and it made me reconsider
and I really liked Texas and Mack Brown
and everything about it and of course
I'm gonna make the change and I had
confirmed my father and everybody like
hey Dad I'm gonna change go to Texas and
I came home from school one day and he
had the phone there ready for me and he
just goes go ahead make the call and I
was like oh can you do it now Tennessee
would they just won the national title
with teamwork exactly right they beat
Florida State in that national
championship game and yeah what made it
even worse then is when I called him
this is how he answered the phone and I
really still feel bad about this right
because I have tremendous respect for
Phil Fulmer but he answers the phone he
goes Chris Sims how you doing buddy I'm
in Alabama recruiting you to receivers
right now and I was like oh man coach
I'm not coming and he was like whoa well
what and that's I went from there yeah
that was brutal did you make the right
decision oh did I make the right
decision I do believe I made the right
decision yes did I go through some bumps
and bruises at Texas certainly I do I
think they had a hard time accepting me
to a degree cuz I was a Yankee in their
eyes playing quarterback for their
football team I really think it came
down to that in a lot of ways but man
yes it's in a phenomenal school I wanted
to be a part of the back of the uprising
of Texas and at that time you know
Rickie willing to just won the Heisman
that the team wasn't that good and I
just thought wow this is special to be a
part of this program on the rise again
I really felt like it actually made me
mentally tougher for the NFL that was
the biggest thing because they they file
you like a pro team down there and I
know that you cover the NFL primarily
you also worked with Notre Dame's
coverage but is Tennessee a great job no
I mean this was a little frustrating to
me first of all what they did to Greg
Schiano
and I'll say this Gracie Anna's from my
hometown he went to my high school so
he's a guy that yeah I'm a little jaded
with this whole thing that's gone on
here but the way they did him is just
outright disrespectful and no it is not
a great job Tennessee needs to be
reminded that this is not Tennessee of
Phil Fulmer and the you know late 90s
early 2000s where he had this thing
rolling that was a special circumstance
there's not a lot of in-state talent in
Tennessee
I lived there plan for the Tennessee
Titans I mean those high school games
there they weren't even in the same
classes that Texas are a Florida or in
New Jersey or some of them so I think
from that aspect you got to remember
they have to recruit nationally and then
they have to recruit against Alabama and
Georgia and Florida for all the same
kids there in the southeast and they're
not gonna win that battle most times
Chris Sims joining us here in the man
cave Mike sous-chefs people join us
coming up next hour do you want to play
the Kirk Cousins game we played earlier
sure okay do you have the music there
for the Kirk Cousins or game you have to
pick Kirk Cousins or the quarterback you
get five years the next five years
Kirk Cousins okay okay here we go with
Chris Sims
Kirk Cousins or Matthew Stafford
I'm gonna go Matthew Stafford because
Matthew Stafford is one of the five best
quarterbacks in football for me I mean
he's one of the greatest throwers of the
football in the history of the NFL I
mean gosh she's never had pass
protection or a run game his whole
career he is phenomenal and he can carry
a team by himself
Kirk Cousins or Matt Ryan ooh man that's
a close one gosh you know really I'm
gonna tell you I would take Kirk Cousins
I know that's gonna shock a lot of
people I think the physical ability is
very similar
I think Kirk Cousins has more physical
ability I would agree really I was just
gonna kind of break it down and go he's
probably a little bit better too athlete
he's got a stronger arm you know of
course he hasn't had Julio Jones and
Kyle Shanahan and those teams around him
his whole career and some of that
offensive talent regardless it's a close
one but yeah I think I would go Kirk
Cousins Kirk Cousins or Cam Newton ooh
for five years whoo man I'm still gonna
go Cam Newton but that's a close one as
well because what worries me with Cam
he's physically more gifted as well but
will it Teeter off here just because of
the physical beating he's taken through
his career but I'm still gonna go with
Cam Kirk Cousins or Andrew Luck oh man
that's the night you look at you you're
coming in hot here yeah ah man Andrew
Luck with this shoulder situation and I
have to take this into account of me we
don't know what's happening or anything
you know because of that I'm gonna say
Kirk Cousins he's not nearly as talented
as Andrew Luck I mean Andrew Luck is a
you know ultimate big-time franchise
quarterback but the shoulder situation
is it is worrisome to me I saw this
report it was a column Pete Prisco who
was an analyst with the NFL is Kirk
Cousins the most overrated player in the
NFL Wow I mean that's a little
ridiculous okay is he the most overrated
quarterback in the NFL Wow no I don't
look at it that way I mean so we're
talking about the quarterback who's
second in the NFL in passing that has
had a beat-up offensive line all year no
running game and an average defense and
he's thrown 21 touchdowns and eight
interceptions he's overrated I just I
don't understand that now as Kirk
Cousins one of the five best
quarterbacks in football no does he even
one of the 10 best probably not he's
definitely in the top half of football
he's somewhere in that discussion
between 10 and 15 or 10 and 16 certainly
so if Washington wants to get rid of him
go ahead tell me who you're gonna get
that's better I'd like to know that but
also Washington kind of put Kirk Cousins
in this position of everybody's going
wait yes they're not committed to him so
how good can he be it's almost
year-to-year you have to prove yourself
and then I think Washington's going to
end up losing him I agree and then try
to find somebody when they could have
three years ago signing up to a
long-term deal saved money and you do
have a franchise do is he a franchise
quarter he is a franchise quarterback
yes you can win a Super Bowl with Kirk
Cousins hands down certainly and I think
the thing I look at too I mean Dan he
feels disrespect
that he should I mean the organization
didn't want to ever give up the dream of
rg3 I mean right that's so this is where
this is all started from in my opinion I
mean Jay Gruden his first year there I
mean he had a fight off the RG three
mafia because man he should be played he
did four years ago oh that was four
years ago we don't give a damn it's a
now it's what have you done for me now
League so I don't understand that aspect
of it again Kirk Cousins yes he might
not be a super superstar quarterback but
he is really good and he's playing
really good
why isn't RG three in the league or
getting any mention at all I know he had
a trial I think was San Diego right but
nobody brings up his name we talked
about Colin Kaepernick sure like why
isn't RG three get the chance I think
he's he's proven to be a handful off the
field
I think he's proven to be injury prone
which is gonna scare people he's kind of
a polarizing figure in the locker room I
don't think people want to deal with it
a little bit where they just go oh we're
gonna have him be the backup and get you
know a ton of attention and hold press
conferences every day you know coaches
in the NFL they don't want to deal with
that crap so I think from that and yeah
the fact that I do think there's a knock
on our g3 that he wasn't coachable plain
and simple
I do want to ask you this go back to
Kirk Cousins have one more time and that
is that you had Steve Smith senior
Marshall Faulk talking about cousins not
being a leader that he didn't go over
and put his arm around Jameson Crowder
and say hey I'm coming back to you and I
don't know the whole leadership thing
right you know Russell Wilson there's a
knock with his teammates that thought he
was out for himself he was in the leader
Aaron Rodgers wasn't a leader by right
you know current or former Packers there
is Kirk Cousins not being a leader and
because of that Steve Smith said he
might have cost himself 10 or 20 million
dollars but because he didn't say keep
your head up yeah is that what we're
saying yeah man that's that's what the
coaches will evaluate they're gonna go
in the offseason and go hey you know
when he threw that interception do we
want to pay him 20 million because you
didn't say keep your head up I know he
made 30 great throws in that game to
make him almost win the game no of
course not that means nothing and how do
we know the relationship I just don't
understand the I don't understand the
harsh criticism that Michael Irving and
Steve Smith gave him after the game I
don't I mean I was more in the lines
with what Chris Collinsworth was
during the game that whoa he is playing
phenomenal
he can't block everybody he can't catch
the ball for the receivers and what gave
Jameson Crowder more confidence in the
fact that he came back to him like what
five more times during the game so I
just don't understand that that's that's
media bull bull crap well but I also
like I get too much comfortable with you
you're coachable it's like if you miss
five shots and then the star comes down
and he throws you the ball again that
tells you something in basketball like
he's still going to me right yes so
that's what I would think if I said if I
don't go to you then I'm telling you so
a lot of players don't even want to hear
it like if I made a mistake I didn't
need like some offensive line or
defensive guy to come up to me go hey
keep your head up
Brady do that though I mean he might but
he might not it depends on the guy I
think it has to do with the personal
relationship and knowing where you're at
in the game and knowing that individual
player - how he handles you know the ups
and downs of an NFL football game will
continue with Chris Sims I want to ask
you about Eli Manning okay was it worth
all of this
news and headlines that Eli got demoted
we'll talk about that with Chris Sims
after their Stan Fallon show Chris Sims
pro football talk co-host with Mike
Florio staying with us in studio Eli
Manning gets benched yeah five games to
go Weiss is such a big deal I would like
to know the same thing I you know again
I understand Eli Manning's you know
borderline Hall of Fame quarterback I
mean I'll go out there and said he's the
greatest quarterback in the history of
the Giants even better my dad my dad
says gonna cut me out of the will when
he heard me say that the other day but
you know III understand there's never
gonna be an easy time to do it right
you're gonna get backlash no matter what
if they did it in the offseason people
would call it and go well why didn't
they bench him during the season cuz we
could have seen what we got with Davis
Webb and Geno buh-buh-buh okay the plain
and simple you know facts of the matter
is Eli Manning has not played well plain
and simple period he didn't really play
all that well last year either except
they just had a great defense and Odell
Beckham jr. made a play from now and
then to get them over the top right I
don't think they've scored over 30
points in the last two years so you look
at things like that and then
yes he's getting up there in age he's
being paid like he's Aaron Rodgers so
every now and then you got to make a
play like that and I'm not trying to sit
here and be critical of Eli but I just
don't understand the backlash and I
guess the people saying it wasn't done
in a correct way what other way is there
to do it but if if they bring in Davis
Webb and I said a Gino Smith I think
people would have a problem you're
you're right in New York I think that's
a big problem
a giant tanking no the JA I think it's
the opposite I think that's what they
told you a Gino Smith they want to win
this week they're telling you they think
Gino Smith is better than Eli Manning
and I know that's a hard reality want to
win because coaches go to their graves
with these records on it and he didn't
Ben McAdoo he's gonna fight to win every
game here down the stretch because if
they win what the last few games he can
have a 500 record hereafter to see
nobody cared I know but it'll look good
and somebody will fall into it idiot
GM's and people fall for the numbers
trick every year he got the job cuz of
crap numbers oh you lied Manning threw
for 4,000 yards yeah you guys were 6 and
10 great what does that mean I don't
understand he got the job cuz of Aaron
Rodgers and his great numbers and people
thought oh he must no offense and those
had a coach a quarterback no Aaron
Rodgers is amazing that's why he's there
sorry final two minutes alright the
Jacksonville Jaguars you will blank
because of Blake bortles well
underachieve you know I think they're
gonna get in the playoffs are they a
great team they are the best team in
football Dan Patrick the best team the
problem is they have the 70th best
quarterback and I I don't mean to be a
jerk to Blake bortles the facts are the
facts he just can't throw the football
and yes David Caldwell his ego at the GM
position has cost them a chance to win
the Superbowl they are a team with that
old line the receivers they got Leonard
for Nets one of the freakiest running
backs to ever come into the NFL and then
the defense is an all-time great defense
I mean this is 2015 Broncos 2000 Ravens
type defense where they are winning
games almost by themselves they are a
team I look at that go they can match up
with a Brady in New England and give
them a tough time except I just don't
know if they could score you know 17
points or 14 points to actually win the
game disability of the best quarterback
I truly will tell you that I do
think every backup in football is a
better thrower than Blake bortles yes
plain and simple you've said this that
he's actually a left hand he's
left-handed but he wait he throws
right-handed yes he's left-handed that's
left everything we've ever heard he's a
left-handed he was only recruited by one
team to play quarterback and that was
Central Florida so again I like Blake
bortles the person and I know it I think
they picked him for all the wrong
reasons though because he's a handsome
guy and he can command the room and he
could be a later leader and he looked
good in front of the podium except you
know it's kind of important to throw the
football at that position I just a
little I left handed he's Chris Sims Pro
Football Talk co-host and former NFL
quarterback by the way and his dad at
the second best may be second best
quarterback in Giants history oh maybe
I'm third now I don't know gosh Charlie
Conerly my except he's pretty good where
they were pretty good you're right
thanks for stopping by thanks right to
see him for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]